los votantes estadounidenses no eligen
directamente a su presidente son en
cambio los representantes llamados
electores y quienes tienen la última
palabra sobre quién llega a la casa
blanca en total hay 538 de ellos en el
colegio electoral el número en cada
estado varía según su población
california han estado con más cantidad
de habitantes se tiene 55 alaska en
cambio tiene sólo 3 el candidato que
obtiene la mayoría de votos gana todos
los electores excepto en dos estados
maine y nebraska que operan con un
sistema proporcional se necesitan 270 de
los 538 votos para ganar la presidencia
es un sistema que a veces ha resultado
controvertido porque un candidato no
necesita necesariamente la mayoría del
voto popular para asegurar una mayoría
de electores
ese fue el caso en 2016 cuando donald
trump perdió el voto popular pero venció
la gira de clinton por la casa blanca